ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung
heute geht es um das sehr sehr zentrale
Thema recht nachdem wir es in der
letzten Sendung mit dem Thema macht zu
tun hatten da mache ich oben rechts den
Link dazu rein Recht und macht verhalten
sich recht eng zueinander im
politischen Rechte sind häufig bezogen
auf die Grundrechte und wir sehen hier
eine sehr sehr gute Übersichtsseite die
ich finde vom deutschen Bundestag eine
Homepage die ich sehr empfehlen kann da
gibt es im Bereich Service
parlamentsbegriffe A bis Z ist so ein
Art Lexikon und hier findet man auch
unter Grundrechte eine ganz kurze aber
pointierte Auskunft und wenn man dann
hier drauf klickt den Hyperlink dann
kommt man zu diesen Grundrechten die
eben in den Artikeln 1 bis 19 garantiert
sind ich gehe darauf jetzt ein bisschen
näher ein und möchte sie vorstellen
teilweise aber auch problematisieren und
aktualisieren ja so sieht's also aus es
gibt Grundrechte das ist das Recht um
das es eigentlich geht im
politischen Politik hat es immer auch
mit den Fragen nach Rechten zu tun
insbesondere nach
Grundrechten das deutsche Grundgesetz
enthält die Grundrechte von Artikel 1
bis 19 was sind jetzt Grundrechte kann
man sich fragen das sind Rechte die die
Gesetzgebung vollziehende Gewalt und
rechtsprech
als unmittelbar geltendes Recht binden
so jedenfalls die Auskunft des
Grundgesetzes jetzt kann man sich
natürlich genauer überlegen was ist das
jetzt hier Gesetzgebung vollziehende
Gewalt und Rechtsprechung ganz klar das
sind die drei Gewalten das ist die
Gewaltenteilung das bedeutet dass die
Grundrechte für alle politischen
Gewalten im Staat Geltung
beanspruchen das ist die
Legislative also die Gesetzgebung
konkret das Parlament die
Exekutive vollziehende Gewalt ist die
Bundesregierung und die Rechtsprechung
das die Legislative und konkret ist es
das Bundesverfassungsgericht in höchster
Instanz es gibt natürlich noch
Amtsgerichte und so weiter und so fort
aber die höchste Instanz zumindest
bezogen auf Deutschland das
Bundesverfassungsgericht es gibt
natürlich noch höhere Gerichte der
Europäische Gerichtshof und so weiter
und so for aber auf nationale Ebene ist
es die
höchste Instanz die die Rechtssprechung
trifft ja jetzt kann man hier noch ein
paar weitere Fragen stellen Artikel 1
Wie verhält der sich zu den anderen
Grundrechten ist er überhaupt ein
Grundrecht und hier wird's ein bisschen
schwierig er ist nicht auf derselben
Ebene
angesiedelt wie Artikel 2 bis 19 die
Grundrechte ne er ist so ein Art
supergrundrecht könnte man sagen
weil es die anderen Grundrechte erst
begründet ist also nicht so konkret
sonder ziemlich allgemein weil aber so
allgemein ist kann er als Basis als
Begründung alle anderen Grundrechte
dienen wie z.B im Artikel 5 das ist das
Recht auf die freie Meinungsäußerung
darauf gehen wir gleich noch ein
bisschen näher ein er begründet sie
dadurch dass er das Wesen der autonomen
und rechtsfähigen und rechtswürdigen
Person bestimmt er spricht von der
unverletzlichen und unveräußerlichen
Menschenrecht
als Grundlage jeder menschlichen
Gemeinschaft des Friedens und der
Gerechtigkeit in der Welt man sieht also
Artikel 1 mit der Würde des Menschen hat
eine globale Dimension eine Dimension
globaler Gerechtigkeit wenn diese Sache
berücksichtigt wird die würde dann so
die Auffassung des Grundgesetzes dann
haben wir eine Garantie oder gute bas
zumindest für globale Gerechtigkeit und
globalen Frieden häufig entstehen eben
Konflikte auch dadurch dass diese
Grundrechte nicht zugestanden werden
oder infolge von Konflikten verlieren
sie ihre Geltung was heißt jetzt
unveräußerlich und unverletzlich
unveräußerlich bedeutet dass diese
Grundrechte nicht von einer Person
gelöst werden können sie machen eine
Person erst zu einer Person zumindest in
politischer Hinsicht in moralischer
Hinsicht sich fragen ob da noch mehr
dazu gehören muss aber aus politischer
vielleicht auch juristischer Sicht sind
das diejenigen Grundrechte die eine
Person ausmachen ohne die eine Person
nicht gedacht werden
kann und deswegen ist auch der Artikel 1
so wichtig weil er das ganze die ganzen
Grundrechte bezieht auf diese Würde der
Person jetzt müssen wir uns mal ein paar
Grundrechte genauer anschauen ich würde
vorschlagen Artikel 5 freie Meinung
äußerung Grundrecht auf freie
Meinungsäußerung und wir sehen in Zeiten
der Digitalisierung wird der etwas
problematisch warum wir können jederzeit
an jedem Ort unsere Meinung im Internet
oder anderen sozialen Plattformen
konkreter Twitter und so weiter eine
größereen Öffentlichkeit mitteilen also
Öffentlichkeit öffentliche
Meinungsäußerung ist in Zeiten der
Digitalisierung sehr leicht möglich man
ist sehr schnell mit einer Meinung in
der Öffentlichkeit und das kann
passieren dass wir dann die Grenzen
dieser freien Meinungsäußerung auch
überschreiten na wir finden nämlich im
Absatz 2 von Artikel 5 ein paar
Informationen darüber wo die Grenzen der
freien Meinungsäußerung liegen und die
finden sich dort wo es um den Schutz der
Jugend geht und auch vor allem um das
Recht der persönlichen Ehre was heißt
das jetzt wir dürfen nicht so weit mit
unserer meinungsäusßerung gehen dass wir
darin andere Personen beleidigen
beleidigen vielleicht schon aber nicht
so beleidigen dass wir Ihre persönliche
Ehre verletzen was ist denn jetzt das
die persönliche Ehre und ihre Verletzung
es geht darum dass unsere Meinungen
nicht eher rührig sind und das heißt so
viel wie diffierend wenn wir also
anderen Personen etwas unterstellen z.B
unterstellen sie sein verbrecherisch
wobei sie es nicht sind und in andere
Dinge gravierende Dinge unterstellen
dann überschreiten wir die legitimen
Grenzen unserer freien Meinungsäußerung
darin lit also ein
Problem das war in aller Kürze ein paar
Gedanken zum Begriff des Rechts aus
politischer Hinsicht konkret am Beispiel
der Grundrechte Artikel 1 bis 19 des
Grundgesetzes vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit bis zu einer nächsten
Folge